you did something I find very admirable
you've opened up recently and started
talking about your battle with
depression and you're so glad you
brought that up yeah yeah well you know
you steered me into an area right admit
I'm not the jock everyone thinks I'm you
how about your your battle with
depression in this special that you did
and I'm guessing that was a conscious
decision you felt like it's time to talk
about this now
it was conscious but also I was so sick
like I was so shaky and I was fighting
when I live all the time when I get
anxious and I was just because you were
having what were you doing the height of
your depression yes yes it was coupled
with anxiety yes a wonderful companion
to depression is is the is the nerves
and the shaking and so when I would go
on stage it was so clear there was
something off that I had to address it
before I could get into talking about
sweet potato fries and candy corn and
things that aren't that important I
hadn't talked about depression and then
it just it grew and I had people who
encouraged me to expand on that and also
the audience's feedback was so positive
they that I felt like I was connecting
with them at a level I hadn't by talking
about the state abbreviations more
people are think about depression yeah
their lives and they do about the state
abbreviation right ugly but no but I
think that that is a service I think
it's it's probably very healthy for you
do you get that because you went through
a real serious phase of depression and
went and got help yes and and got
medical help and then you come out of it
and by talking about it I think you are
letting a lot of other people know
rightfully in comedy this is a huge
right well I went from never telling
anybody about it and and it was pretty
serious I mean I was hospitalized for
weeks at a time and right and had a
treatment that's very unusual to most
people which is electro convulsive
therapy which we mostly know from One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest so you had
it's used to the term I usually call his
electroshock therapy was the old term
for I'm hoping it's more sophisticated
now than it used to it
is but the name seems like kind of a
lateral move from electroshock to
electro convulsive yeah yeah it sounds
worse like they were they were saying
how could we make this more horrific
yeah to the people going once sounds
like a metal band you know let's go see
like a convulsive right they were
concerned that maybe they were soft
selling the convulsions yet they should
really you had that play that is really
incredibly serious treatment and then
you weren't really able to function like
immediately afterwards no just no and
and I moved back into my mom's house and
Peabody Massachusetts why where I grew
up and my mother is so optimistic and
lovely but she's in a little bit of
denial so even when I was moving back
into her house she she didn't think it
was that serious she was she wasn't as
afraid as some of us were but the
hospital was the thing that I was so
terrified of going because of movies
like One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
thing and Girl Interrupted
and it was so ordinary
it was like a college common room
basically with a TV and and the only
thing was that they watch Steve Harvey
they watch Steve Harvey yes okay yes and
that's the is that part of the treatment
I think that was that might have been
the punishment Steve's a good friend but
too much of anything can't be good yeah
right so it was very ordinary although
the the phone cord when I would call
home to my wife was was very short it
was yeah it was right like a candlewick
it was so short right and it didn't
occur to me at first and then I thought
oh I know why they yeah so yeah yeah
it's a safety thing yeah well I'm really
glad that you you got help I'm really
glad that you got help because you're a
brilliant well being
that's you're very nice sorry you know
and you're a really nice person and I
think talking about that is extremely
important it's a lot of other thank you
I'm so grateful to be healthy and
feeling well and I want people to know
that they're they're not alone if
they're suffering with this and that
there's another side to this and there's
hope which there were times when I when
I was hopeless I really didn't think I
would ever come out of it and I I got a
job as a camp counselor at my friend
Brian's camp in Beverly mass right
because I thought I needed a new new job
but eventually I came out of it thanks
to a psychiatrist and a family and my
wife Shaw day and and friends so I could
list a dozen things in addition to
medicine that shot a the singer
I really like just thought you were
throwing it in there to your Meritage
Sade
I usually say not the Shaw day you're a
a Shaw day okay yeah I I'm not sure if I
were to say you know what really help
get me out of my depression marrying
shot a yes really got me the royalties
from smooth operator Hey nicely done
yes is what would have got depression I
play it right now but we can't afford to